revue de presse signée sandrine comes
bonjour sandrine bonjour philo nous
commençons par nous intéresser à cette
enquête du site en ligne russe médias
zona alors médias zone 1 donc c'est un
site indépendant qui aujourd'hui est
inaccessible en russie et ce site donc
amené site d'information a mené une
enquête sur les pillages menés par les
soldats russes en ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre le site fait état de
56 tonnes de marchandises qui ont ainsi
été envoyés en russie ils analysent et
les colis envoyés depuis quarante-six
succursale d'une société russe de
livraison à ceux des camps situés près
de la frontière ukrainienne en russie en
biélorussie mais aussi en crimée à
annexer des colis prétendument envoyés
par des soldats russes identifie ici
souvent par leur poids chaque colis
dépassant généralement plusieurs fois la
tête d'un colis moyens
le site analysé des connexions
inhabituelles entre entre plusieurs
villes des flux anormalement élevé qui
confirme selon ce site d'information la
version d'un pillage de masse les
soldats des soldats en uniforme ont par
ailleurs été vus en train d'envoyer par
exemple des baskets des pneus des
téléviseurs et des conserves en gros
tout y passe voilà pour ses 50 tonnes de
produits qui ont de fait été volés
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
ce drame maintenant dans une maternité
au sénégal onze bébés qui ont perdu la
vie mais cet incendie qui s'est déroulée
dans une maternité publique d'où la
localité de tiva tivaouane à l'ouest du
sénégal mercredi le gouvernement a pris
acte philo mais ces dernières heures de
la gravité des faits face à une
population qui demande aujourd'hui des
comptes et bien vous le voyez le
ministre de la santé diouf sarr a été
démis de ses fonctions remplacé par la
directrice générale de la santé le pays
qui a aussi décrété trois jours de deuil
national la presse régionale elle est
particulièrement critique ce matin selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète on le
sait
court circuit en serait à l'origine de
cet incendie problème ces incidents dans
les hôpitaux ont tendance à se répéter
ces derniers temps le quotidien
burkinabè l'observateur paalga dénoncer
ici une série noire vous allez voir d'un
système sanitaire malade le 27 avril
encore quatre nouveau nés avaient déjà
péri brûlées dans un autre service de
néonatalogie death et aline guéret dans
le nord du pays cette fois on avait
alors parlé d'une défaillance du système
de climatisation
alors ont surgi on suggère ici ce
quotidien de faire appel à un marabout
pour conjurer dit-il le mauvais sort qui
transforme les maternités sénégalaise en
chambre mortuaire pour nourrissons même
fatalisme à la une d'un autre quotidien
burkinabé le pays
l'émotion en attendant le prochain
sinistre titre ce journal le sort
s'acharne-t-il sur le sénégal ici on
espère que des enquêtes vont permettre
d'établir les responsabilités il faudra
que le cas de tivaouane serve de déclic
dit le pays le journal qui conclut la
plupart des centres de santé au sénégal
comme ailleurs en afrique sont des
mouroirs qui ne disent pas leur nom fin
de citation un autre scandale sandrine
est à la une de la presse vendredi il
s'agit d'une affaire inédite dans le
monde de l'art qui a un retentissement
mondial oui c'est le trafic qui fait
trembler les musées au pluriel c'est la
une de libération ce matin avec sur fond
de vous le voyez de deux pyramides hull
du louvre car c'est vraiment cette
institution du monde de l'art qui est
éclaboussée aujourd'hui il s'agit ni
plus ni moins d'antiquités qui pillaient
qui ont été explosées exposé dans
plusieurs musées
le quotidien a eu accès à des documents
confidentiels il revient sur ces
révélations sur cette mise en examen
hier du de l'ancien directeur du louvre
jean luc martinez pour blanchiment
complicité d'escroquerie en bande
organisée
il est accusé notamment d'avoir fermé
les yeux sur l'acquisition de plusieurs
oeuvre notamment par le louvre d'abu
dhabi qui a rapporté ensuite beaucoup
d'argent au louvre à paris on lui
reprocherait de la négligence d'avoir de
complicité
lors de l'acquisition de plusieurs
pièces en parle de pièces
exceptionnelles provenant de pays
instable des pays parfois en guerre
voilà qui ont été vendues avec de faux
certificats sur le marché de l'art avec
la complicité des experts c'est un
trafic d'une ampleur inégalée à un titre
encore libération ce matin une dizaine
d'oeuvres acquise par le musée d'abou
dhabi mais aussi le met sont concernés
le museum of art de new york qui avait
notamment acquis un sarcophage dorée du
prêtre net j'ai manque il a dû
finalement être restitué ce sarcophage à
l'egypte il avait été dérobée en 2011
lors de la révolution contre l'ancien
président si moubarak libération qui
conclut dans son édito qu'il ya encore
fort à faire pour contrôler un monde de
l'art encore opaque et puis vu d'espagne
ce el país qui titre sur un scandale en
france qui parle d'une affaire digne
d'une histoire de tintin pour ce journal
d'autres personnalités du monde de la
culture et de l'archéologie en france
pourrait être impliqué dans cette
nouvelle malédiction de toutankhamon qui
fait trembler les institutions et le
gouvernement aussi rapidement cette
histoire qui tient en haleine des
passants et des internautes en france
depuis une dizaine de jours une orque
s'est perdu dans la somme il avait été
identifié
vu pour la première fois le 16 mai entre
honfleur et le havre est depuis dix
jours cette orques de 5 m r dans la
seine son état de santé est extrêmement
dégradée les spécialistes sont inquiètes
c'est un animal qui vit en plus tôt en
mutants avec des plus tôt dans les eaux
froides vers la norvège vers l'irlande
voilà on espère aujourd'hui peut-être
que son instinct la poussera vers la mer
en tous les cas elle à 65 km de la
manche actuellement il faut lui
souhaiter qu'elle retrouve son chemin
merci beaucoup sandrine domaize petite
pause n'a pas aidé avec lens koto dans
un instinct poindre au journal